que disent les cinquante citoyens qui
ont réfléchi sur les bêtes à la
quasi-unanimité ils ont rejeté le projet
initial en clair moins de logements et
la préservation des jardins c'est
finalement le début d'une réflexion
d'une société qui s'interroge sur quels
sont les choix que l'on doit opérer
que faire maintenant de cette parole
quelle place lui donner au sein de la
gauche qui avait défendu le projet la
couleuvre est difficile à avaler
les communistes veulent des logements
sociaux mais n'iront pas contre la voix
du peuple
si on décide d'aller en contradiction
totale avec ce qui a été dit par la
conférence itunes et dès que je pense
qu'on n'aura pas compris n'aura pas
compris ce qu'est la démocratie à notre
époque quoi en tout cas du côté des
socialistes la sphère est plus sensible
le projet dévêtent pourrait-il être le
caillou de trop dans la chaussure de la
majorité municipale
il y avait déjà le contournement de
besançon souhaité par le ps mais refusé
par les verts le projet de grandes
bibliothèques retoquée par madame la
maire un bug politique est il possible
un jour oui c'est possible ça dépendra
du sujet du dossier qui sera présenté
lors du conseil municipal du mois de
septembre
oui c'est pas sûr qu'ils aient un
consensus au sein de la majorité
municipale sur ce sujet c'est possible
que pense la principale intéressée
anne vignot la maire de besançon ne se
prononce pas pas encore
quant aux socialistes elle connaît
l'étendue de leurs nounours les
socialistes c'est pas quelque chose
d'homogène heureusement et c'est ici du
collectif donc les socialistes vont
regarder les pros communisation regarder
les arguments et vont travailler dessus
il ya des dossiers sur lesquels on ne
sera pas d'accord voilà mais ça la vraie
vie moi ça n'existe pas à le grand
consensus
ou alors il ya quelque chose de louche a
derrière le grand consensus écologistes
socialistes communistes ont tout l'été
pour trouver un terrain d'entente
refermer un dossier ouvert il ya plus de
15 ans et pour lequel plus de 5 millions
d'euros ont déjà été déboursés